well I think what's important for
members of the public actually is not
the personalities involved but can you
actually do what you say
we know from the Labour Party that
actually they make a lot of promises
some of which they've already rode back
on they made a promises on student debt
during the election campaign which
they've now rode back on but they we
know that they cannot deliver on what
they're promising by taking a balanced
approach to the economy we know that
when we say we're going to do something
we will be able to do it for the people
can you not concede though that in this
grand journey to try and attract young
people back to the Conservative Party
that part of the problem has been your
tone and your plan on brexit I think
it's important for us to get brexit
right I think it's important for us to
show that getting brexit right isn't
just about those who voted leave during
the referendum it's about the hold of
the country it's about making sure that
we can build that global Britain in the
future that does ensure prosperity and
jobs and a better future for people
across the whole of the United Kingdom
so how does it help when the foreign
secretary says things like people who
fly EU flags on protests have genuinely
split allegiances and may questions
their pride in the country what is
important is that we build the global
Britain that can ensure that everybody
can see a better future in this country
they've been strong feelings on this
issue of Europe and I recognise that but
the job of government now is actually
getting on with the negotiations and
ensuring that what we get out of this is
the right deal for the UK but
questioning the patriotism of young
people some of whom were protesting how
does it how does that help you with
young people well I think what we need
to do with young with in relation to
young people is actually show how we
will deliver for them I think that's the
important thing for us to do there's a
split in the generations but this
obviously still a split in your cabinet
how can you tolerate as Prime Minister a
foreign secretary timing his red lines
to be released to the public while still
having dinner with the eu27 how can that
do anything other than undermine our
negotiating position well you know I
think leadership is about not about
having a lot of yes-men sitting around
the table with you but having people
with different views but I also would
say this to you that the
a lot of focus in conversations about
the foreign secretaries job about this
job in the cabinet that job in the
cabinet actually what members of the
public are most interested in is that
they don't is what we are doing for them
they want us to be concerned not about
our jobs but about their job they want
you Minister and your chief diplomat is
there on the day or meeting at you 27
saying things that are not quite in
accord with your negotiating position
and feels free just say them no and but
as I say actually leadership isn't just
about being surrounded by yes men and
what is important for this country is if
you look at the Union you negotiations I
negotiate with EU leaders David Davis
negotiates with Michel Barnier the
government's position is very clear
because it was set out in the Florence
speech Boris was part of the cabinet
that agreed to that position in the
Florence speech and that's the vision
that we take into the negotiations and
we take forward to other uu leaders and
we've already seen that just beginning
to change some thinking I put an offer
out there as to what the future
partnership for the UK and the EU could
be now we wait to hear from the EU what
their responses we've just heard from
the European Parliament who have
rejected the idea of sufficient progress
by 557 to 92 yes and I don't think that
vote was particularly an unexpected one
but the great wealth is unwelcome but
the question isn't so much around this
formal declaration of sufficient
progress the question is are people now
thinking ready to think about what the
future partnership between the UK and
the EU will be now we have to get to
that at some point I believe it's
possible to come to a good deep and
special partnership because it's good
not just for the UK it's good for the EU
as well and what I hear is that people
are starting to think about that one of
the primary aims of a prime minister
will be to unite a country that was
divided after the referendum do you look
at the country and actually see it as
more United now out there in the public
in your cabinet in your party from when
you became Prime Minister because
doesn't seem like that
I think that rod divisions in our
country I think there were divisions
between young and old I think there are
divisions between those parts of the
country that feel they've they've
benefited from economic growth and those
the feel that they haven't that's why
what we're talking about this week is
building a country that works for
everyone you're prioritizing your party
over the country uniting a divided party
over the interests of the country
now what we're doing is actually
addressing the issues that show
divisions in across the country such as
the divisions for those who do feel left
behind making sure that the economy is
working for everyone across the whole
country